dormir sur le côté si vous vous endormez
sur votre bras vous risquez de vous
réveiller avec le bras tout mort et ça
c'est pas très agréable
d'ailleurs spontanément dans ces cas là
on se dit que si on a le bras tout
engourdi au réveil c'est parce qu'en
dormant dessus on a coupé la circulation
sanguine c'est pas faux mais c'est pas
la seule raison c'est surtout parce que
quand tout notre poids repose comme ça
sur notre bras ça comprime les nerfs qui
sont à l'intérieur et quand ils sont
comprimés bah ils arrêtent de
fonctionner correctement nos nerfs il
faut savoir qu'ils ont essentiellement
deux fonctions il s'occupe de la
sensibilité c'est à dire qu'il donne les
sensations le toucher etc et il s'occupe
aussi de la motricité c'est à dire que
c'est eux qui envoient des impulsions
électriques à nos muscles pour les faire
fonctionner et donc quand nos nerfs sont
comprimés ils aiment pas trop ça du coup
ils se mettent en grève si vous voulez
ils arrêtent d'envoyer leurs
informations du coup non seulement on
sent plus rien mais en plus on peut plus
bouger alors bon c'est pas dangereux
mais si on a le sommeil très lourd et
qu'on reste vraiment très longtemps
endormi sur son bras le réveil est pas